[Music]  Shia LaBeouf has a run-in with the law  the actors started live-streaming from a  Donald Trump protest in New York City on  inauguration day and plans to keep it  going for four years took a hit for us  but the protests took a turn on Thursday  morning the 30 year old was arrested  after getting into an altercation with a  fellow protester each he confirms the  fight broke out when an unidentified  person allegedly said something that  upset the actor LaBeouf allegedly  grabbed the man's scarf pushed and  scratched him the buff was arrested then  released  he's charged with misdemeanor assault  and harassment and is scheduled to  appear in court on April 7th